today's video is brought to you by why
stamp but more on that a little bit
later you may or may not be aware of an
ever-growing architectural trend in the
residential and luxury end of
architecture what i'm referring to is
the beautiful winter balcony screens so
what my sole purpose is here today is to
teach you the simplest and easiest way
how you can go ahead and create any
winter balcony screen that you're
looking for so let's turn around to this
screen and get started with today's
tutorial today's video sponsor is why
stamp and if you've never heard of wire
stamp before that's probably because you
have a terrible email signature
now why stamp is basically a free email
signature generator that's designed to
make it as simple easy and convenient
for you as possible you can easily go
onto ystab's website sign up to a free
account start generating your email
signature within minutes and have it up
and running one of the best things is
that you can quickly and easily change
any of their template designs available
and replicate them to your branding
requirements so for me personally it's
very simple it's black and white so i
was able to change all of their colored
templates do exactly what i needed and
then quickly change between all of the
templates to see which one i liked best
i settled with a nice sleek
sophisticated template with a nice strip
across the bottom that displayed all of
my social media icons on top of that i
was also able to provide a footer
underneath my email signature with one
simple click now i didn't have to worry
about any legal jargon i could just
simply click on that little footer and
it was automatically generated for me
now if your email signature looks like
two lines at the bottom of a page i
truly suggest you check out the first
link in the description down below and
step up your email signature game so in
today's tutorial we're going to be
starting with a blank template use
whatever template is available to you
this one is in the production mode and
it's taking a long time to create but
we're getting there slowly so let's
simply start with a slab at the bottom
let's run it 30 meters
by approximately 10 meters it gives us a
very generic rectangle to start the
process with what i'm going to do is
simply click on that rectangle click
command t open it up i'm going to
overwrite all of those settings i'm
simply going to paint it white and then
i'm going to extend the actual height of
that slab so let's make it 2745 as if it
would be a realistic full ground floor
next i'm going to hold alt come up one
floor right click on my floor below and
show is trace reference and then i'm
simply going to draw my secondary floor
above
which is what we're going to be using as
our winter garden up top so we want to
overhang the front of it as much as we
possibly can and just simply create a
generic shape i'm next going to just
introduce another shape here at the back
drag that back in line hang it over a
little bit
and then i'm going to introduce a larger
shape in the middle to simply just give
it some sort of architectural flair in
our massing today if we marquee this
shape and open it up in 3d we're going
to see a very generic very boring shape
but if we extend this ground slab all
the way to our top slab extend our
architectural feature down and up ever
so slightly just to make some random
shapes and then reposition these shapes
so it looks a little bit nicer from 3d
now looking at again in 3d we can see
we're starting to create a winter
balcony at the front here very simple
very elegant very slim so what i'm going
to do is introduce one side blade wall
here on the left hand side a concrete
roof and a very simple slab on ground
coming back into 3d i'm simply going to
delete that massing use my slab above
let's drop that 150 ml duplicate it to
the floor below so we see two slabs in
our picture
and i'm just going to change these
straight to concrete now we're starting
to form some sort of architectural shape
some sort of architectural flair
these walls are quite low quite narrow
for me so i'm going to extend them a
little bit higher in our project not too
high not the full length of that wall
next to us let's call it 3 8
and then i'm also going to do something
a little bit sneaky and extend that down
a little bit as well so what we're going
to do is we're actually going to
increase the size of our winter balcony
without increasing the size itself
lastly if we extend the roof height of
this let's drop that
300 millimeters below the top of that
concrete slab so now we have a very nice
3.2 meter ceiling last but not least
let's just add a little bit more of some
architecture here let's give that some
stacked stone work
and then come back to our first floor
plan
introduce a simple balustrade in front
of our balcony so we know exactly that
there is a balcony there when we open up
our winter balcony if we come back into
3d we can see we've created a very basic
very simple stainless steel balustrade
we can adjust any of those settings like
we always do in the command t section or
opening up all of those settings now
this is where it gets interesting and it
starts to really look like a winter
balcony what i want to do is take this
bottom slab and i want to move it back
120 millimeters or whatever wall
structure i'm going to use as a result
coming back to my first floor i want to
draw a brand new wall structure
regardless of what it is and simply draw
it at the edge
of our winter balcony
so if i was to look at this in 3d what
we'd be seeing is a very simple balcony
here and that wall would need to be
extended from the very top to the very
bottom
and for architectural sake i'm most
likely going to actually drag that back
500 millimeters
which is going to allow me to drag back
my slab to the inside of that and also
push my balustrade back ever so slightly
now looking at it from a very quick
generic perspective it looks like i've
just simply drawn a big blank wall but
this is where it gets very quick very
easy and one of the best tools in our
cad so we want to come back to our first
floor plan we want to find and isolate
that wall that we just spoke about we
want to come into our door tool we
basically want to find a bi-folding or a
parting door so if we scroll through all
the available options that archicad has
available to us we're going to find a
sliding folding multifunctional door now
we can use any that arcade has by
default if we wish to or we can go ahead
and make our own
so let's select one of these random
doors as an example let's go with this
larger one here and then let's drag and
drop that somewhere into our project so
here straight away we have a number of
doors available to us and then what i'm
going to do is basically divide our
width which is almost 15 meters by the
number of doors let's call that 12 or 13
dollars total so coming back into our
settings six doors on one side six doors
on another side so it stacks and opens
the full way across we want to press ok
we want to extend our door all the way
the full width and then once again we're
going to come into our settings
go to our hv grid and open up our hp
grid settings what i want to do is
change all of these to 25 25 25
vertically i only want one pane down the
bottom i want 12 on each so now if i
come back into my final model attributes
i can simply change that
to a nice walnut vertical press okay
come into our 3d model see what we've
created and basically extend this to the
bottom of our wall and extend this to
the top of our wall and now we have the
startings of a winter balcony but how do
you know if this is a winter balcony or
if it's just another random screen well
if we open up our settings come all the
way up to our opening type and length we
can start opening up our sides if we
come into our opening settings go into
width 3d and type in a number that we
see appropriate for our louvers and our
screen to move go two meters in this
instance we'll see that our bi-folding
sliding track is utilizing the top and
the actual concrete itself if i wanted
to i could continue extending that all
the way across or utilize the hot links
in this project to basically extend it
as far as i needed if we wanted to part
these individually one way or the other
we could go further and replicate this
bi-folding screen over and over again so
we can split each individual panel in
two in a butterfly formation or however
we best see fit one of the easiest ways
to achieve this look here is to simply
reduce the number of bifolds to one on
each side and replicate that door over
and over again until we are satisfied
with the desired look